all right we have a trailer for ant-man
and the Waze is danza me I haven't done
a trailer video for ant man in the wasps
we've been in the wasp trailers that
have happened that have come out I just
haven't done videos on it but coming off
the heels of infinity war I figure I
might as well do one on this a man the
last trailer just came out what it does
well right out the gate is it shows how
bumbling he is and how efficient she is
I mean that was the argument in the
first movie I saw some Twitter chatter
about how some people thought it was
[ __ ] that she didn't actually get
the suit and how she was so much more
efficient than him and it was sexist
that you didn't get the suit when that
was a plot device it was like the point
like the movie agreed with them and they
didn't even know it the point is now
Evangeline Lilly is the wasp and she is
way more efficient than he is he's like
bumbling fumbling bumbling desire yet
let's take care of business and now
there's this new villain using Hank Pym
technology you can walk through walls
they can phase through walls which I saw
in an episode of Fringe was never sewed
of Fringe and I usually dealt with that
point is she could walk through walls
one thing I don't like is the
description of her motivation granted
it's Michael Pena saying it maybe he's
just saying it in a jokey jokey manner
but he says now supposed to take over
the world or whatever like all right we
have ourselves a 90s villain nineties
villain to destroy the world then again
if you look at a lot of the MCU villains
that they've had kind of the same
motivation redelivery just makes me
think 90s in a world where that 90's
title is the title that's a 90s
motivation it doesn't meet villain
though in a world where you don't want
another ant-man yellowjacket it's just
the same villain kind of thing going on
uses the technology but uses it
differently this does take place before
infinity war right like I heard it dead
but I heard from the internet I heard
from Internet people on the internet
that it does this phase through matter
ghost lady wants to take over the world
or whatever it was before Thanos so we
know that doesn't happen whereas after
Thanos and what a step back cruisers
before Thanos stuff but as for ant-man
and the wasp they do either work well
together or the wasp works very well in
which case Scott Lang's gonna give us
some comic relief let's see what the
saltshaker is pretty boss Rob and she's
a really good aim could she just like
shrink people there's like you're all
small now I'm gonna put you in these
mason jars where you can't bother
anybody I get that scene right there
because if I had the powers to commune
with ants I would have a big one in my
house guarding my house and you would
probably be playing the drums
I feel like Scott Lang is bringing rock
band back for everyone who lived in a
college town in the mid-2000s and the N
Laurence Fishburne and Scott Lang are
comparing how big they've gotten cuz
yeah I know it's a cliche I know it's a
joke but dudes are like that every road
trip we've ever done that our friends
have also done we
compare our times every score we do in a
game we compare our scores honeys after
the craziness of infinity war I feel
like it's gonna be fun to kind of put
our feet up and have ourselves a little
sequel to a heist movie I don't know if
this is gonna be eyes movie I'd be a
heist movie in the sense that the ghost
person is hi sting something I'd have to
stop that person from hoisting something
which case maybe it's the anti heist
movie well I set the trailer for ant-man
and the wasp have you seen it what did
you think about it are you looking
forward to it after infinity war looking
forward to a relaxing fun time away from
the stones away from the drama
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]